hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
the roman emperor julian also known as
julian the apostit because he turned
away from christianity and towards
the old gods and towards greek
philosophy
has a discourse which is
called to the uneducated
cynics it's a it's an oration and you
could think of it as
a a criticism of how
cynicism was being
portrayed exploited lived out in his
own day and early on in the text he
tells
us about what he thinks philosophy is
in part because cynicism is a
mode of philosophy he's actually going
to say
in in some sense it's a universal
philosophy
but before he gets into that he wants to
say well what is philosophy
in the first place and so he tells us
uh quite a bit if we
move past the initial oration part
he says let me sit down for the benefit
of the public what i learned from my
teachers
about the cynics so that all who are
entering in this way of life may
consider it and then he says okay if i'm
going to pursue my argument
from the beginning and do order giving
each question its proper treatment
what i first have to do is say cynicism
is a branch of philosophy
and so i have to say a few words about
philosophy
itself what is philosophy as
an activity as a discipline as
a way of life as a way of
using one's own human faculties
to do something it's good to remember as
well
that this is not somebody who is
philosophizing about philosophy or
engaging in meta philosophy we would
nowadays call it in a vacuum
it's been going on now for centuries and
centuries there are many philosophical
schools and texts available
and there's many people who are living
it out and representing it
so he begins by talking about the gift
of the gods and you notice that there's
a lot of reference to
stories coming from greek mythology here
and these are being interpreted in an
allegorical way which was quite common
by then
so he says the gift of the god sent down
to mankind with the glowing flame of
fire
from the sun through the agency of
prometheus along with the blessings we
owe to hermes
is not known other than the bestowal
of reason and mind this is what is
distinctive to human beings
for prometheus the forethought
prometheus that that's
what his name actually means that guides
all things
mortal using a fiery breath to serve as
an operative cause
gave to all things a
share in incorporeal reasons so the idea
is one that was quite common in ancient
times that there is a providential
ordering of things
and that the very ways in which the
degrees of being
were arranged given their particular
endowments
is reflective of that providential
ordering what's what's also kind of
interesting about it is
each kind of being participates in that
in its own way so he says
each thing took what share it could
so some things can't do as much right
lifeless bodies only a state of
existence a remaining
in being a hexis is how it's framed
in the greek to plants they get life
that's nice for plants right
for animals soul tsuke right
and for a human being a
rational soul a reasoning soul
a soul that has logos a soul
that has so much more capacity than
a mere animal let alone a plant let
alone a stone
so he says some think a single substance
is the basis of these others they differ
essentially according to their species
we're not going to worry about that
we're not going to get into that
metaphysics
it's enough to realize that there is a
hierarchy of being
and we are on the higher wrongs because
we have
reason and so he goes on and he says
we want to say whether one regards
philosophy as some people do
as the art of arts or the science of
sciences
or an effort to become like god as far
as one may
or whether as the pythian oracle said
it means know thyself it will make no
difference to my argument why not
because according to julian all of these
definitions all of these
ways of understanding what philosophy is
are closely related to each other they
overlap
if we look at them so it's not a matter
of you know a multiple choice test and
pick a and if you pick a you can't pick
b right
this is more like an essay where you
show how things are
connected with each other so how do we
define philosophy we've
just isolated four different ways the
art of arts
right the techne that that is in some
respect over or governing the other
techniques
the science of sciences an effort to
become like god
to you know as much as we can to engage
in theosis
or to know ourself and these turn out to
be
all connected so he says let's begin
with know ourself
why because it's divinely inspired so
it follows what does know itself
actually mean it follows that a person
who's going to know himself doesn't know
just particular things like oh i'm
wearing this tie you know
and where did this this tie come from oh
i bought it a long time ago
and this is my favorite shirt that fits
me and i like to wear it
and it just came out of the wash a
couple days ago it's not all that trivia
right
it's knowing what you are
not just knowing yourself as an
individual knowing yourself
as a human being what does it mean to be
a human being it means that you have a
body
maybe you are your body it means you
have
a soul consciousness the capacity to
think to engage in
reasoning about yourself it means you
have other things in your soul too like
he talks about the emotional parts
right but these are important aspects so
we have
body and we have soul and he says it
will
not be enough to know that we are a soul
employing a body
we're also going to have to know the
essential nature of the soul what is
this thing that
that i'm conscious of being and then we
trace out its faculties
memory for example or imagination
or sense perception so he says this is
not alone for
enough for him but in addition he will
investigate
whatever exists in us nobler and more
divine than the soul
that's something which we all believe in
without being taught and regarded as
divine
and all in common supposed to be
established in the heavens so we're not
just going to learn about ourself we're
also going to learn about
what if there's anything in us
corresponding to the divine
what it would be we're also going to pay
attention to the body he says
as we investigate the first principles
of the body we observe whether it's
composite which it is or simple which
it's not
and proceeding systematically will
observe its harmony that's it's we could
say
it's equilibrium or however else you
want to frame it what kind of dynamic
system of systems this body is
and the influences that affect it and
its capacity and in a word all that it
needs to ensure its permanence and then
he says
in the next place he'll also and here's
where we start leading into the arts
observe the first principles of certain
arts
by which the body is assisted to that
permanence
for example medicine like you know how
do we
make the body healthy how do we preserve
its health right and which ties in with
diet and exercise
in the ancient period or as he says
husbandry now that's a little harder for
us
to connect with that means like farming
and growing
things that's very important for us as
human beings unless we want to be
hunter-gatherers right uh so
in a pre-industrial society we need to
know about
these things it's probably a good thing
if we know a bit about where our
food is coming from anyway right so he
says of
other arts that are useless and
superfluous
now you'd expect him to say well you can
put those aside but julian says
he's not going to be altogether ignorant
why because
these have been devised to humor the
remember i just spoke of it the
emotional
part of our souls julian buys into
something like the platonic tripartite
soul
where we have reason as one faculty we
have the appetites
as another faculty located primarily in
our belly and in our genitals
and then we have fumos this this thing
that gets riled up inside of us
and is contentious and wants honor
revenge
gets angry all of that sort of stuff so
arts that can actually
help you deal with those are important
he says
we will avoid the persistent study of
these
because we're not going to be you know
involved with that but
we shouldn't remain in ignorance of
their apparent nature and what parts
of the soul they suit so now here we get
to self-knowledge
and the other key ideas
self-knowledge as he says reflect
whether self-knowledge does not control
every science and every art the word
that he's using there is just
techne but that could be science
medicine is a techne
we also think of it as a science and so
knowing yourself leads us to needing to
know about these
different sciences or arts or
disciplines
whatever we want to call them and it
also
doesn't just know them it controls
them or at least leads them right the
greek word there
is more like leading or directing
and it also grasps the universals the
catholone the thing that pertains to
everything of that that class so if
we're going to talk about bodies
what is it that makes bodies bodies well
that's part of the universal
that it grasps so he says to know things
divine through the divine part in us
mortal things through the part of us
that is mortal this is the duty of the
living organism that is midway between
these namely
man because individually were mortal but
regarded as a whole were immortal and
moreover singly and universe
individually component compounded of a
mortal
and an immortal part now that's that's
typical platonic ideas the
immortal part is our rationality
so this is is quite important this is
leading us to thinking about god
he tells us to make oneself like god as
far as
possible is is what to acquire knowledge
of the essential nature of things
as is attainable by mankind and here he
says something that does tie in with
cynicism as well as other philosophies
what does it mean to
be like god it means to be happy and it
means to be
self-sufficient god doesn't need stuff
god isn't in
necessity or want like us
human beings he says we count the divine
nature happy
not because of a score of abundance of
possessions
why why is the divine nature happy he
says well it's because as homer says
the gods know all things that's why
they're actually happy so we want to be
like that as well
uh later a little bit later on he says
what we are sometimes god is always
right and so we you know we want to be
as much as possible like the
divine and that means knowing things
it also means having self-knowledge god
presumably would have
the greatest degree of self-knowledge
and that's part of why
god is happy or the gods or whatever the
divine
nature happens to be so
the other thing that he says that's very
important in this section
is that although we human beings tend to
break philosophy into different
divisions
we say i'm doing metaphysics or i'm
doing logic i'm doing ethics over here
from the right perspective philosophy
is one single whole it is a
unity rather than a plurality
and so he tells us that let no one
divide philosophy into many kinds
or cut it up into many parts let no one
make it out to be plural
instead of one for even as truth is one
so to philosophy is is one a little bit
later
he tells us truth is one in philosophy
is one and they who i'm
who i just spoke of now are its lovers
one and
all right and so
why then you could say wait a second
truth is one
philosophy is one but i think there's
there are a whole bunch of different
kinds of philosophy and there's lots of
different truths aren't there
from the perspective that julian is
articulating
there is yes there are a number of
different things like that
but if we treated them systematically if
we
tried to take the god's eye view
which is not just some abstraction but
actually
the right way to look at things we would
try as much as we can
to unify these into one single
perspective so this is what julian says
philosophy is and what it aims at as
philosophy in in the very general sense
you